[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight
the palace invites the public to swear
allegiance to the King and his heirs and
successors at this week's coronation is
it a patriotic boost for a people
celebration or a tone deaf misstep it's
a gift for the doommongers will debate
Silence of normally sensorious Guardian
journalists on a shocking anti-semitic
cartoon just a week after a sister paper
published a shocking anti-semitic letter
because the British left have an
anti-Semitism problem and a problem with
rank hypocrisy
she's the lungs of a Nation for me the
new Dame Vera Lynn World world-class
songstress Catherine Jenkins is here to
kick off a week of Coronation
celebrations with a world exclusive
interview and a series of nightly
performances just for us
[Music]
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored well Canadian
from London and welcome to Facebook on a
bank holiday I know what you're thinking
he's underpaid he's overworked and they
even drag him in on a bank holiday but
that's that's how you get to the top
commitment and dedication on days when
everybody else is having barbecues and
lying by the beach not me oh no oh no
it's coronation week and like it or not
the eyes of the world are on the British
Monarchy this will be an historic State
occasion to put it in context think
about this the procession on Saturday
will be twice as big as the procession
for the Queen's funeral three times as
big as the procession for the Platinum
Jubilee this will be the biggest
celebration of our monarchy and British
modern history since of course the
Queen's coronation back in 1953 But
ultimately it belongs to the British
people
the monarchy belongs to the British
but in trying to make precisely that
point the palace has begun this
momentous week with what looks to me
like a bit of a misstep and I'll tell
you why in a striking change to an
ancient ritual the watching public will
be invited to pay homage to King Charles
by reciting an oath of Allegiance
something normally reserved are after
character acts in Westminster Abbey it's
supposed to make the service inclusive a
people's coronation they say but instead
it's played into the hands of the
naysayers and Republicans bent on
souring this coronation scenes like this
up at Celtic feel like a kind of
inevitable response to being asked to
pay homage and bear allegiance to the
king
oh
thank you
[Applause]
well utterly Charming of course as ever
from Celtic fans but that's what they've
always been like towards our monarchy
and I have a similar view of Celtic fans
so all's fair in Love and War now
they've got mixed feelings obviously
about this they're not even mixed really
I've got mixed feelings too because our
King has earned Allegiance from us with
the longest apprenticeship in history
and a lifetime of Duty and service I
will defend King Charles and the
institution of the monarchy to the hilt
as a unifying force for good in his
country but as always the devil lurks in
the detail the order of service will say
all those who so desire in the Abbey and
elsewhere say together I swear but I
will pay true allegiance to your majesty
so look so far so good I've got no
problem with those words I can imagine a
lot of people are home actually say yeah
I can say that I can go along with that
nothing dictatorial about that bit
all those who desire can get involved
all those who don't desire can keep
their big gobs shut or change the
channel or go and watch Celtic but then
the oath concludes with this and to your
heirs and successors according to law so
help me God
and this is where I've got a problem
the king's heirs and successes well they
include a rather unsavory bunch of
characters that many British people
might rather lock in the Tower of London
than pay Allegiance and homage to let's
not forget that Prince Harry the great
Royal traitor is fifth in line to the
throne despite having done more than
anybody living memory with the possible
exception of his wife to trash and
undermine the institution was supposed
to be celebrating
a little further demo list is prince
Andrew eighth in line to the throne who
recently paid a woman he said he'd ever
met 11 million dollars to avoid getting
into court to contest a sex abuse
scandal his calamitous PR decisions have
heaped Global embarrassment on the
Royals now I believe passionately in the
British Monarchy but I'd rather be
garotted frankly than swear my
allegiance to either Harry or Andrew and
I suspect most British people feel the
same in a severe cost of living crisis
and with polls showing more than half of
the British people don't care about the
coronation especially young people the
idea of pledging allegiance to an
unelected head of state feels like the
wrong answer to a serious question if
King Charles wanted this to be an
inclusive gesture maybe a better place
to start would have been shelving the
oath altogether or doubling down on the
message that he like all harmonics lives
in service to all of us
well joining me now is also in the story
in Dr says that Dunlop and talk to the
presenter Rosanna Lockwood and former
Royal correspondent Michael Cole well
welcome to all of you so Tessa
I don't know why as soon as I heard
about this oath and I heard it came from
conversation in the ospreads with
Canterbury to Lambeth Palace and
Buckingham Palace and Charles and so on
it just felt like they taught themselves
into what they all thought was a good
idea but in the cold light of day when
they've seen the reaction even for a lot
of people like me who are pro monarchy
even I was wincing a bit and thinking
have they really thought this through I
know even you yes Sarah Vine there was
this wonderful moment of unity between
left and right everyone feeling a little
bit queasy but you know what the problem
is Pez when we drill into you beyond the
Tiaras and the tinsel I would question
whether you really are a monarchist
because the point is with hereditary
monarchy you don't get to choose and
that is where this oath is all wrong
because it's reminded us of the horrible
Inconvenient Truth that hoisted above us
as our head of state is someone we have
no sales I have no problem with that if
the head of state is
hang on you've had your say yeah just
for the record I am a monarchist and I
do believe in the royal family and I
think they do more good than harm but
Rosanna the this the problem with the
oath is
right now I'll pay allegiance to King
Charles because I think he's earned it
right but I'm not you know there's some
problem he's not there suddenly you
can't pay an oath on conditions though
peers you can't say I'm going to
withdraw this at a later Point why
should it be in perpetuity for everybody
else on the cab rank I am going to
listen to the historian Tessa Dunlop on
this and that that is how inherited uh
you know power works but I'm glad that
you brought up and you're opening
monologue that point about dictatorial
because when I was thinking about this
there's something quite Soviet almost
about everyone
um looking towards a TV set yeah and
pledging Allegiance the TV set does they
say it was an invitation you're not
compelled to do it obviously but you're
not going to get police running into
houses arresting people but but I agree
it did have a slight Kim Jong-un feel
yeah right you will all I mean you can
all agree on these things but I don't
actually agree with you I think they
were trying to conjure up ideas of Mary
England and the maple the leader
instructor the Medieval Times where is
the green man it just failed that's all
well okay let's bring in Michael Cole
um Michael you'll be listening patiently
here what do you think of this oath
well appears as you've said it is an
invitation to people to make an oath of
allegiance to the King and his and his
successors and like any invitation to a
dance or to a wedding it can be declined
or it can be accepted it is an attempt
and I think it's a well-meaning attempt
by his majesty the king to involve as
many people as possible it may be that
some people don't want to they may sneer
at the idea they may be part of a
metropolitan Elite but there are many
many people around this country and
around the world who will welcome that
opportunity to play their personal part
in the coronation hang on okay hang on
Michael do you actually think that large
groups of people in homes up and down
the country are going to sit around the
television and recite this do you really
think that's going to happen
I do and I'll I'll tell you why because
this is notionally a Christian country
and many people are not observant but
most of us given the right occasion will
stumble our way through the Lord's
Prayer and we will take comfort in that
and I think people will actually feel
involved and let me just say something
about hereditary monarchies there is are
in the country in the world 43
monarchies and there are 149 republics
so there's plenty of choice and by and
large the monarchies are the happy lands
and the republics are not necessarily so
I know you think you're the statue of of
Royal statistics so what about this one
so I saw on Twitter tonight I loved
the United Kingdom is one of only two
countries in the world that have
monarchies
where the coronation is a Christian
service can you name the other one
uh well of course the the King has 14
overseas Realms like Canada
Australia no no it doesn't include I
mean actual individual countries which
have a coronation
probably
um
probably sick him in the Himalayas
apparently he couldn't this guy on
Twitter a historian is Tonga is the only
other place which actually has did you
get that right no we didn't I would love
to pretend I did but of course she she
stole the show at the at the 1953
coronation yes looking extraordinary in
a downpour I've got a question for
Michael can we go back to him as he's
such a believer in US notionally
remembering the Lord's Prayer and
likewise this Pledge of Allegiance can
you pledge it down the lens right now
have you learned it off by heart
no I haven't but I have got written down
because I'm prepared to be on the Piers
Morgan show the oath that uh Prince
William is going to swear oh yeah and he
says I William of Wales do become your
liege man of life and Limb and of
Earthly worship and faith and truth I
will bear unto you to live and die
against all manner of folks so help me
God wow and that was from the days when
yes indeed that was one of the days when
it was important for the Monarch to
establish who his friends were a
monarchy and a coronation was a matter
of life and death you see I would only
this is very very important I to be
honest with you I would only say stuff
like that to Thierry Henry or Dennis
Bergkamp and your wife a possibly Lord
both of them Ian both of them that's
about it three sporting ledgers
I want my chance with Michael now
because I want to speak on behalf of the
sneering Metropolitan yes given that you
know I'm a sort of millennial journalist
type even though I know live in the
countryside in a village but I think
what people are doing here when they're
saying I don't really want to swear
Allegiance you know they may feel
agnostic about the royal family but the
other key thing is they're using their
brains their critical thinking functions
their their brain capacity which is
something when it comes to the monarchy
in this country and God bless this
country I love it so much people seem to
sort of remove their brain when it comes
to the monarchs and they just sort of
follow through and I think that's what
this quote unquote sneering Metropolitan
Elite your target all right you've
answered you've answered the charge very
well I want to move on to the other
stories been bubbling today a new
interview with the Markle family uh led
by Thomas Markle who of course had a
stroke a few months ago and was actually
quite seriously ill after it and he's
given a new interview and she talks
about Meghan Markle effectively treating
him like he's dead let's take a listen
let's go somewhere in the park
and I say what's wrong what what
how can I fix this how can I fix this
of course I love you and and the bottom
line Harry I
nice guy I love you for married with my
daughter Meg I love you I love my
grandchild two children
I would love to see them
and open to any kind of conversation
I mean I found that pretty sad actually
I mean whatever your view about this
family War that's going on he hasn't
seen his daughter for five years now he
lives 70 miles away from Montecito it's
an hour and a cab and he's a Broken Man
by the look of it he's obviously got a
lot of health issues now since the
stroke hence his voice and so on but you
take your hardest and my issue again
with Megan Harry they preach a lot about
compassion the Archer World Foundation
is all about compassion where's the
compassion for this guy even if he is
giving another interview which drives
them nuts as he says what else can I do
he's got nothing else he can do yeah I
think
ah do that felt like lifting a lid and
looking at something that I felt I
shouldn't actually be seeing right it
was I agree we all felt uncomfortable
very tough watch a very tough watch you
want to get in the house of Montecito
knock a couple heads together and look
time's not on your side just taking one
look at Thomas Markle but Harry and
Megan bonded through pain their
childhood pain
that's if they both carry
massive elephants in the room skeletons
from the past difficult childhoods that
we can't fully understand well hang on
I'm sorry but we can't she went to live
with Thomas Markle for years right so
whatever pain it was probably involved
her mother at the time but hang on we
don't none of us we know she lived on
her own with Thomas for years none of us
know we all know that the optics for
Megan would look better if she could
reconnect with her father for some
reason she doesn't feel able to present
it's just a Tory and sad State of
Affairs when you've got a family
communicating via exclusive TV
interviews and Netflix special he would
have been paid handsome very very
handsomely and you know it's awful to
watch a man who is so sick appealing to
his daughter like that using a TV show
however of course you receive payment of
course
um you know Megan and Harry have come
out and said that they felt exploited
yeah because the one thing those two
don't ever want to do is sell their
privacy for money I mean obviously it
would be the last thing they'd think of
uh Michael Cole you reported throughout
periods of unbelievable Royal traumas
the Diana Camilla Charles Trilogy and so
on
um what happens to them I mean it seems
to me what's going to happen if if this
plays out the way it looks like it's
Thomas markle's gonna die and he's going
to die without ever being reconciled
with his daughter and it's just going to
be on any level a human tragedy right
that's deplorable and it's very very sad
and if Meghan Markle looks into her soul
she will recognize that her father was
the her entree into show business
because he was a very skilled television
lighting man a chief man he wasn't just
the man changing the bulbs he was the
man making the pictures look good and
that's how she got into show business
that was her entree and now we've got a
situation where Prince Harry is not on
speaking terms with almost all of his
own family and she is not on speaking
terms with any of her family apart from
her mother and one niece so you've got
to ask yourself in all of this why is
that as it is well I'm doing the math
and I'm working out who the problem is
you know my thing is they've been joined
you say by terrible experience I think
they've been joined by a love of
victimhood which is a modern day curse
and a love of weaponizing things like
mental health racism and so on to
promote their brand and make themselves
stinking rich I really do and I know it
sounds cynical to say that but I am very
cynical about what they've been doing I
do think that's what they've been doing
both of them would argue it's a chicken
and an egg which came first Thomas
Markle Prince William has been through
exactly what Harry's been through
exactly the same he's ever sold out oh
hang on a minute who's got the second to
one big gig on Saturday you cannot
compare the experience of William versus
Harry going back to that Allegiance you
know what when I go home for a family
dinner I get the last sausage it's what
happens what happens when you're the big
boy when you're the first born when
you're the eldest you get a few treats
in life me the extra sausage William he
gets to wear a crown and be king I said
you can't make a comparison yeah my
siblings don't like it either but tough
titty anyway many of your family talk to
you do you wanna they all talk to me and
you know what if one of my family uh did
what Harry's done I that would be it and
what if your dad did what Thomas Markle
did he wouldn't well unlucky you lucky
you that you have a dad you can I
wouldn't ostracize him and I mean
Harry's never met guy Harry's never met
the man whose daughter emo it's
unbelievable that is something
unbelievable I mean seriously it's
ridiculous I think the way given the way
we're talking just unbelievable is Harry
actually what is truly unbelievable is
that sadly we have to lose you now we're
cutting you I'm afraid you're out uh
you're being replaced brutally and
heartlessly not because of your views
but because we're moving on to another
statement it's been lovely to see you
Tessa as always uncensored and uncansled
it turned out well uncensored next uh
silence and the normally sensorious
Guardian newspaper journalist on a
shocking anti-semitic cartoon just a
week after it published a shocking
anti-semitic letter what the hell is
going on at the guardian what is this
staggering obsession with being
anti-semitic and where is the hypocrisy
of these sanctimonious commentators
remember they were founded on slavery
these people
that we need to have a chat about the
guardian off the break
[Music]
foreign
I've been photographing the same family
for 45 years
I followed their lives across four
generations
thank you
sir
I think about what I've done and who
I've met and what I've seen I can't
believe it
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Piers Morganite says
that the guardian is Britain's woke
Bible it Revels in its self-appointed
roles the nation's morality police for
the second time a little over a month
it's been forced into a groveling
apology for its own foul play first it
said sorry on his front page for its
Founders links to slavery and now the
editor's facing calls to resign after an
anti-semitic cartoon this weekend caused
outrage in the Jewish Community the
image in Saturday's newspaper used
anti-semitic tropes in a grotesque
caricature of outgoing BBC chairman
Richard Sharp is Jewish sharp was
depicted within a large nose carrying a
box stuffed with gold a squid and prime
minister Rishi sunak's head and Pig's
head was featured behind it the image is
clearly offensive but no prominent
Guardian commentators have joined the
near Universal condemnation can you
imagine if the Sun or the times or Daily
Mail had done something similar with for
example a Muslim public figure the
hypocrisy of that silence is deafening
and outrageous and this of course
follows the Observer which is the
guardian sister paper publishing that
now Infamous letter from Diane Abbott
the labor politician in which she
effectively said that Jewish people only
suffer the same kind of prejudice as
people with red hair well joining me now
has taught to be presenter Richard
science talent agent Jonathan Charlotte
and Rosanna still with me so yeah
Rosanna let's talk about the guardian
what is going on at the guardian I knew
you'd come to me because you know I take
Umbridge with your points given that it
is my woke Bible right of course you
know I love the guardian I think it's a
great newspaper some brilliant jobs
working there this lapse is absolutely
abhorrent though absolutely as was a
Diane Abbott letter as well there needs
to be some serious questions there but I
do think it's a great paper stuff with
great journalists why are none of those
great journalists on Twitter doing what
they normally do when a newspaper
commits an outrageous active
anti-Semitism or racism and that's
expressed their indignant personal
wounded Fury that is shocking to me you
would expect somebody to break ranks
because you know working in within news
organizations often wear hands strung by
what we can and can't say on social
media and what the bosses want to say or
not but journalists need to have
inquiring minds why aren't they speaking
out against this it has been not as loud
as you would hope from uh
absolutely silent I mean Richard there's
a rank hypocrisy never mind the offense
of the cartoon now I know Martin Rose
and he's a brilliantly talented
cartoonist but this was immediately I
saw I was like what the hell have they
done because it followed also followed
the Diane Abbott thing in the in the
guardian system how could one Media
Group get it so badly wrong in the space
of about eight days the first one was
was pretty unforgivable but I think this
is actually as bad or worse and how the
editor is frankly still in the job
because as you said if it was any other
media organization there would be
screams and howls of condemnation saying
resign resign here if that happened here
we'd all be asked to us I mean Jonathan
make it up you've worked in the media a
long time you're one of the top at
Talent representative management guys I
know you're Jewish what did you think of
this I mean this is now first dianaba
and now this both from the same Media
Group and it's the Media Group that
leads the woke stuff the one that leads
the charge against friends they were so
guilt-rid and ashamed by the discovery
that hundreds of years ago their founder
may have employed slaves they've paid 10
million I think it is to ease their
guilt in reparations and so on how can
they keep being so blind about
anti-Semitism is it the same reason
Jeremy corbyn and his labor party were
so blind it's actually maybe quite a few
of them are anti-semitic well I think
clearly they might they might say
they're not anesthematic but there must
be a degree of antisemitism certainly
subconscious anti-Semitism because how
can you let how can one wheat you be
saying Jews in the Holocaust is the same
as a redhead being picked on at school
six million Jews Gypsies Travelers and a
redhead being picked on on teased I'm
not defending redheads being picked on
on teas but you can't even make no
comparison and now and now
if it was a black person there'd be
great great race crime prosecutions
possibly the edits would have gone by
now and the fact that people even think
it's okay I'm hoping that come the
working week starting tomorrow things
will actually happen because Talk's easy
over a busy weekend well the guardian
loves accountability and everybody else
where is the accountability he appears I
mean come on there has to be some
someone has to go it can't keep carrying
on like this week after week oh we're so
sorry we're so sorry where's people like
Gary lineker you quite happy to say that
the government shouldn't appoint a
chairman where's he on this people do
not view anti-Semitism like they view
racism that's the fundamental issue
which is staggering because six million
Jewish people were murdered in a
holocaust simply because they were
Jewish or more glaring example of racism
it'd be impossible to find do you think
that the the nation needs a renewal of
Education or something like that because
it just seems like Mass scale ignorance
on the part of a lot of these media
organizations that are doing this at the
the moment they didn't realize the
cartoonist that I didn't know that it
was not mascow it's one media
organization the guardian Media Group
they're incompetent they're anti-semitic
someone needs to be held to account at
the top okay look let's move to
something else which I found in a very
different way very unsavory uh and it's
Leeds United Football Club who had a
nightmare game at the weekend they got
stuffed and they're a group of people
waiting as they left the hotel where
they've been staying for this game
including a young kid a lead show look
what happened let's just watch a bit of
this
these players you've already disgraced
themselves on the pitch totally ignore
this key
headphones in
marching past or actually diverting to
avoid him a little boy I've been that
kid when I was young and my little
shirt waiting for Frank
mcclintalka Bob Wilson it would have
been Unthinkable when I was that boy's
age
1972-3 right when I was eight or nine if
I was that kid for these players to have
done that then Unthinkable what has
happened to these footballers and we saw
by the way I'm not going to spare my own
team we saw the same thing with Arsenal
players uh about two weeks ago similar
kind of scenario with a young girl right
like here where again they all came and
signed uh segment not one of them
engaged eye contact not one of them
talked to her even said hello and she
kept looking up like that I've got a
daughter A desperately wanting one of
them to just show some kind of interest
and they've all got their earphones you
know they all just marched on again now
apparently in both cases there were
other times in the day when they did
whatever whatever these videos show what
they show Richard yeah it happened to
basic respect for fans a decency look I
think it shows they're out of touch I
think it shows their elitist but most of
all where's their passion for their club
and their supporters who actually drive
everything who motivate everything that
that's part of the passion you can have
Passion of the on the pitch but where's
the passion for the question you've
wrapped a lot of big stars you
or one of them treating fans like that
what would you say to them I'd pull them
up on it immediately and remind them
they're only there because of their fans
peers I hate to praise you but I see you
out and about people come up be mobbed
yeah I mean it's it's Relentless the
truth is you always give time to people
want to say hello always you know why
you know why when I was a kid my brother
Jeremy is a British army officer till
very recently just retired we used to go
down to Sussex County cricket ground and
we go every home go get on the train
Mama job is off we get on the train and
we would collect autographs for years we
used to collect albums full of things
and we can remember to this day the ones
who treated us like dirt they are
mentally scarred into our minds and I
always vowed if I ever got to be famous
I would always sign every autograph I
was asked pose for every picture and
never be the ones who left me and my
brother we can remember them they've
been stayed 50 years later the ones who
treated us like that Rosanna if you
forget about your fans I'm not sure why
you're in any game football
entertainment journalism anything that
brings with it a form of Celebrity
Status why are you in that if you're
actually gonna shun your your viewers
your fans The Spectators whatever it may
be they say never meet your Heroes and
I've met plenty of senior journalists
who I hero worship well I don't know I
mean yeah there we go around the table
with them and uh was disappointed quite
frankly
but on this point I've always said
football isn't the beautiful game I'm
afraid that a lot of football supporters
think it is and it has because there is
this attitude of behavior you don't see
rugby players doing it yeah exactly I
would think you'd see rugby players
smiling you know signing the signatures
there is something at play here within
the mindset of young footballers
overpaid the headphones in that is so
look at that boy
just one of you so sad at least
acknowledge you you can just let down
the club right on the pitch you were
useless it's the money
it is it's too much money I don't think
Alex Ferguson would have put up with
that I was going to say it's failure of
management leadership because the
managers and leaders of the club should
be telling these young guys how to
behave they know there's going to be a
short walk they know their fans there
yeah it doesn't take when you're 30 40
50 000 pounds a week to look your fans
let's move quickly Google bosses have uh
told their UK staff to stop using a lot
of phrases this is part of the woke war
on our language band phrases include
chubby crazy Bonkers which rules out at
least one of my ex-girlfriends kill mad
whitelist and dummy variable right I
mean what is happening Richard Tice
what is happening to our language you
can't call someone chubby what if
they're chubby you can't call someone
crazy what if they're crazy what are
their Bonkers I know people who are
literally Bonkers and mad why can't I
call them Bonkers you can and you should
and we must that's the whole point about
free speech and just telling it as it is
Rosanna are there any limits to this of
course this is ridiculous but I think
what will perturb you more peers I think
if you scratch the surface of every
single especially listed company out
there they are all doing this type of
stuff internally and you would hope the
shareholders would hope that they are
actually you know doing stuff for the
business and focusing on that and I
think the staffers who are spoke to
everyone they said you know we're not
we're kind of I'm going to disagree I
actually think some of the words you've
missed out Blacklist and black hole the
word black is historically negative the
word white is the white the white list
has been banned as well yes but
Blacklist we're gonna ban white list and
Blacklist the answer what list are we
allowing the answer is I looked online
and Blacklist does historically come
from negative so I think you have to be
careful all these things are negative
chubby obviously is not a problem but
what if somebody is literally chubby yes
but equally if you offend a lot of
people with words like Blackness that
shall be considered I think it's very
easy for a group of white I think once
you go looking once you go looking to be
offended once you go looking for
potential racism or whatever it may be
in these things what the guardian did is
serious to me Banning Words which have
been a lexicon of history there was one
in one of the Roald Dahl books they
banned the word a phrase black tractor
as if somehow that was negative it was a
black tractor the tractor was black it's
got nothing to do with skin color to do
with the color of a tractor appears a
lot of the words where blacks involved
do come from negative moments in history
and I think what about whitewash
some words do some words which is what
England will do to Australia this summer
in the ashes right are we going to have
to ban that is that offensive I think
you have to be careful about saying all
words I think once you go down this
slippery slope it's all over every word
becomes offensive to somebody to
somebody they're probably I don't know
how many billions of blacks there are in
the world there's a lot of people to
offend that's not somebody man hours has
been banned you know why sexist that's
not racist we'll end up not talking at
all and that's a terrible Place imagine
imagine Neil Armstrong on the Moon if it
happened today right one small step for
man oops sorry
persons one giant leap for oh no person
kind
but I do think you have to be careful on
some words because a lot of people get
offended and you have no right you know
what people you know what they're all
entitled to be offended and I'm entitled
to ignore them as you do and I do thank
you pack good to see you all and
assistant next to National Treasure the
sparkles in a week it's all about the
crown jewels world-class singer
Catherine Jenkins joins me with a very
exciting announcement about what she's
going to be doing tonight on this show
and every night of coronation
foreign
[Music]
ographing the same family for 45 years
I followed their lives across four
generations
thank you
sir
I think about what I've done and who
I've met and what I've seen I can't
believe it
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook my next guest
is the lungs of the nation love that
phrase an a firm favorite of our royal
family Catherine Jenkins performed
regularly for the late Queen most
recently added Jubilee celebrations at
Windsor Castle Last Summer She's a
national treasure in her own right if
you don't believe me just ask her she'll
soon tell you she's the new Dame Vera
Lim with a unique ability to bring
people together in patriotic stuff and I
couldn't think of anyone better to
perform on my show not just tonight at
the end of our interview but Catherine's
agreed sing every night I've actually
recorded them all this afternoon in the
studio will perform at the end of every
show for the rest of the week leading up
to the coronation ending in a rousing
rendition of God Save the King Catherine
thank you no thank you for bringing your
golden Sparkle dust to the show and I
believe it's the first musical guest
you've ever had you are the first person
to see in our studio yeah how do you
feel obviously the greatest honor of
your life
I've known you a long time but you've
also known the Royals a long time what
does this week mean to you
well I think you know it's it's it's a
huge iconic moment
um you know it's the first coronation of
my lifetime we haven't had one for 70
years right
um as you said I've I've sung and have
met the king many times through our
um sort of shared charity work
um he presented me with my Obe award
which is a really what are these ideas
um I think at the time I was running the
marathon so we talked about my training
comparison
well that's the thing with him he's
always so informed
um last time I saw him it was ITV three
or four years ago and he just came down
the line he was saying hello to Susanna
Reid and all these people he got to me
anyway are you still around
but he is really funny but then we had a
good laugh about Donald Trump yeah he
was all about my interview with Trump um
he said yeah I've always found him very
engaging uh always got a ready quip at
hand yeah and probably the longest
apprenticeship for any job in history
right I mean he's been waiting death
decades to do this absolutely and I
think you know for those of us who have
met him with the different charity
things for example
um I worked with them on the British
forces Foundation you know you can see
that he is as I said informed but really
passionate about those things
um I think he wants to do good in the
world and and I think he has been doing
a lot of good
um you know with sustainability and
environmental issues conservation
um all of those things he cares about
and I care about and so that makes me
really happy to see the thing is it's a
bit like you following I don't know
Barbra Streisand in Vegas right in in
the same theater isn't it in the sense
that
he's following the greatest right the
greatest Monarch there's ever been in my
estimation his own mother and he had to
follow you know succeed if you like
after she had died I mean that's an
amazing thing to think about that it was
the loss of his mother that made him
King on a human level
so difficult to do this and it's got the
whole world watching him yeah and I but
I think that's you know that's actually
a positive is that he has uh learned you
know from her and as you said you know
she was an amazing Monarch well you had
two amazing things with her I mean you
had a lot actually you you performed
before the queen of the royal British
Legion Festival remembrance of alcohol
amazing
um you then sang the national anthem of
the queen of the Derby the big horse
race with her Diamond Jubilee weekend
you were chosen to sing at the Queen's
90th birthday in Windsor uh you then
performed at the Platinum Jubilee event
at Windsor Castle and that was the last
time you sang for the queen but also the
last time you saw the queen and she gave
a little wave and she went it was it was
such an emotional moment
um uh the whole the whole audience were
just so thrilled that she had been able
to attend the event well we've got a
clip of you singing I think from the
events let's take a little look at that
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
wow oh but that was at the end of the
concert she um she she her majesty drove
around and sort of give everybody a
little wave as she left and she pulled
right in front of the stage and she sort
of went oh hello Catherine and I I I
genuinely sort of welled up I thought it
was such such a lovely amazing yeah it
really really was very special but that
was the last time
um that I saw her sadly but I'm so
grateful for the honor of being able to
sing for her well you had another
amazing honor because when the queen
sadly died you were performing a little
event down in Sussex I think a recording
down there and you got a phone call to
tell you this this terrible news but I
love the rest of the country who could
sort of mourn you were asked look it's
the BBC and we want somebody to record
the first version of God Save the King
what an amazing responsibility to be
asked to do that yeah
um I was in a very small beautiful rule
of church as you said with with
microphones in front of me and we get
the call to say we would like to play
this on the BBC in the next hour is it
possible that you can record it and it
felt like one of those things like this
was meant to happen right here I am I
could have been anywhere but I'm
standing in a place with a beautiful
sound and microphones so um yeah we
actually stopped what we were recording
um we we said a prayer
um sort of because it felt strange to
then sing the new words and I had to
think about the new words having Always
sung it with God saved Halloween
um and we all had a little prayer and
and prayed for you know the new rain and
did you find that emotional yeah it was
really emotional
um and it was one of those if I weld up
when I heard the queen had died I mean
genuinely I really felt that yeah I
think we all did that kind of end of
this connection which we'd all had our
entire lives yeah absolutely and to sort
of sing it you know in that moment when
you are feeling so emotional
um but you know something clicked in and
and I sang it in one take but it was
interesting because you know everybody
who's so used to seeing performances and
whatever the minute we went to record it
for the very first time you know
everybody's camera phones went up and
you thought oh yeah this is this is
historical yeah the first time to ever
sing these words so it was a huge honor
did you hear from the King after that I
have not seen him at anything yet but um
you will look forward to you will do and
if you met Camilla I have I have um
so do I I'm neighboring Villages and we
always joke about yeah she's some
pumpkin I'm a newick boy or about a mile
apart and she grew up there with her
family I grew up with mine there and um
she's got that kind of earthy Southern
England local Village Spirit about it
you know down to earth No Nonsense we've
got a picture of you and her there
that's when I remember that's the very
first time I met her anyway
um we sort of hit it off I thought she
was great and
um I've sang A couple of years ago at
one of her charity um I've got her Rhino
on my wall oh
I'm the only person who owns a private
watercolor bike the woman about to be
Queen really I bought it in a charity
auction she gave it to the Daily mirrors
Charity Auction or we bought it in a
charity auction and it's a beautiful
picture of a rhino okay in the bush and
she's signed it and it's on my wall
that's amazing and every time I see her
she opened her opening line is normally
hi Pierce how's my writer which always
makes everyone's eyebrows go up
which I love I think she's great and I
know and what I really like about it she
comes from that old school of Royal Duty
which is never a complaint never explain
and rarely be heard speaking in public
three sentences you could not imagine
being regurgitated by people in
Montecito for example
[Laughter]
have you ever been invited to California
to sing for the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex and I hope I hope if you were
you'd say no
we are actually moving on to the
commercial break I'll let Catherine
sweat for a few minutes and see if
she'll answer that question after the
break or from Catherine Jenkins in a
moment plus she's going to sing for us
and that is worth definitely hearing so
definitely do that
[Music]
I've been photographing the same family
for 45 years
I followed their lives across four
generations
[Music]
I think about what I've done and who
I've met and what I've seen I can't
believe it
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
mode for the coronation coming on
Saturday Catherine Jenkins is still with
me you just told me an amazing thing in
the break that you are in New York at
the end of this week what are you doing
on Friday I'm going to be helping to
switch the Empire State Building into
red white and blue Jack that's
unbelievable I know how fun is that did
you ever think of the little girl
growing up in Wales one day you'd be
turning on the Empire State Building not
at all um it's uh it's I think it's just
going to be a really lovely moment to
start all of the celebrations that I
think are happening Across America
um for for Brits to get involved and
celebrate even if they're not at home
now the other thing is he very kindly
gave me this as well which you didn't
ask me to promote but I like it because
it's a bottle of gin and hey I like gin
um yeah this is your new Venture Gene
yeah if you're going into the whole sort
of brangelina thing of they were the
rose and then Beckham with his whiskey
and they've all got everything like
George Clooney and Tequila right this is
the Genco what was it Jenkins
it's called Signet yeah
um it's it's made six miles down the
road from where I grew up in in Wales
um and no it wasn't like it wasn't
something
no I well I I love gin I come from a
family of I've seen you knock it back
and they wanted to create something that
was like a really high
um Quality Ultra Premium gin with like
all of the ingredients that I love so
for this one
um this is our Signet 22 that's got
Manuka honey in it well you did me a
massive favor why so I was doing an
audio book and if you've ever done them
they are hell on Earth you get put in a
little booth eight hours a day for days
on end I had to do four days and after
three days my voice had gone you just
talked for eight hours a day even by my
standards talking about myself this was
too much my body backed in and so I
messaged Gathering and she said I'm
sending the Cavalry did you know she
turned up at my house I mean it's a bit
stalkerish obviously turned up on my
house 25 minutes later and left throat
tea and Manuka honey yeah and and you
said do that and also sip water all the
time right sit water and my voice came
back yeah so you know it's the same
thing drink the Gin well if I'd known
that was the option it would have made
the audiobook a lot more listenable well
you know the other option whenever you
get a sore throat peers is to go on
vocal rest but I'm not sure if that's
possible I couldn't do permanent vocal
red where do you get these pipes from
when I listen to you saying even now it
just it is staggering the power of your
voice where did that come from
um I don't know but did you first let
loose and think oh my god
um well when I was four I sang in public
for the first time you sang like that
when you were before no but I but I
remember there being a reaction to to it
and and I was always singing because I
loved it I was never thinking about oh
one day I'd like to do this business it
was just a genuine passion
um but do you think you're now a
National Treasure is there still a bit
of work no does anybody think that I do
actually I think you're I do think
you're the new virulin you get wheeled
out for all the big events looking
lovely and you sing beautifully and
Everyone likes you yes I'm very proud of
where I come from and I try whenever I'm
well you're going to sing for us every
night yeah uh every night tonight you're
going to sing
Britannia well Catherine Jenkins thank
you and Catherine Jenkins take it away
thank you
[Music]
who is
this was
[Music]
thank you
Nations
[Music]
[Applause]
monster monster
[Music]
it's time for another way
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been photographing the same family
for 45 years
I followed their lives across four
generations
[Music]
I think about what I've done and who
I've met and what I've seen I can't
believe it
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're